bonsoir et un freedom merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france vous êtes l'un des
signataires de cette tribune d'abord
pourquoi avoir interpellé le président
de la république aujourd'hui lorsque
depuis les années nous protestons contre
la faiblesse des investissements de
l'état dans les services publics dans le
département et cette crise a bien montré
que nous étions très en retard il faut
savoir que moi je travaille au samu et
j'étais de garde
au moment où nous avons manqué de lits
de réanimation en seine-saint-denis nous
étions le premier département d'île de
france a manqué de l'hydre animations
parce que nous avons moins qu'ailleurs
et surtout nous avons eu beaucoup de
malades parce que la population
effectivement de ce département est
constitué de ce qu'on a appelé les
premiers corvée des personnels
hospitaliers les aides à domicile les
éboueurs d'un personnel de sécurité
voilà ce sont des gens qui ont continué
à travailler majoritairement pendant la
crise et ce sont ceux qui sont les plus
maltraitées depuis maintenant à des
décennies par l'état donc nous demandons
des mesures inégalitaires pour la seine
saint denis pour rétablir l'égalité
républicaine c'est très important dans
la période
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la crise a
révélé ou aggravées selon vous dans ces
territoires populaire vous le dites
délaissé déjà des années auparavant par
par la république est bien le prix payés
a été très lourd nous sommes le
département la seine saint denis qui a
le plus de morts rapporté au nombre
d'habitants
voilà donc les personnels qui ont
travaillé dans les services essentiels
sont aujourd'hui dans les métiers qui
sont les plus mal payés en france il va
falloir rétablir ça on a vu un certain
nombre de sondages montrent que la
majorité de la population souhaite qu'on
augmente les bas salaires et qu'on
baisse les hauts salaires là c'est la
grande question des inégalités des
inégalités sociales des inégalités de
revenus et donc il va falloir que ça
change et qu'on arrête cette spirale
infernale des 0,01 pour cent qui gagne
de plus en plus
des millions de personnes qui sont plus
en plus pauvres et qui sont concentrés
dans des sortes de ghettos comme la
seine-saint-denis voilà c'est pas
sérieux
quelle soirée les six mesures selon
voient appliquer d'urgence et ou en
priorité il a écouté les mesures je vais
parler pour celle qui me concerne sur la
santé celle que je connais mieux
il faut arrêter de fermer des lits a
créé était de fermer les hôpitaux vous
savez là nous avons de nouveau des
fermetures de lits programmés dans nos
hôpitaux dans les hôpitaux de
l'assistance publique
le mans dont monsieur martin hirsch le
directeur général de l'assistance
publique à monsieur verront à monsieur
macro arrêter de fermer des lits arrêter
de fermer des lits il faut affecter des
médecins prioritairement dans notre
département dans nos hôpitaux pour que
nous puissions pour que nous puissions
prendre en charge nos patients ce qui
n'est plus le cas à l'heure actuelle
savez là après la crise nous avons une
explosion du nombre de cas de
psychiatrie des patients qui vont pas
bien qu'ils ont besoin de limoux n'avons
plus assez de lits en psychiatrie
aujourd'hui voilà la situation
nous sommes encore dans la crise et de
nouveau et mia les politiques menées ces
dernières années
aujourd'hui aggrave la situation donc
ils font des mesures très urgente très
urgente immédiate et c'est l'appel que
nous lançons avec cette lettre ouverte à
monsieur macro alors vous êtes un
médecin urgentiste est ce que l'on est
prêt selon vos affronter une situation
similaire est aussi grave à la rentrée
que celle que l'on vient de vivre a non
seulement pas et vous savez déjà nous
sommes inquiets pour savoir si nous
allons réussir à passer l'été si on a ce
qu'on appelle une canicule c'est à dire
de forte chaleur ce qui est habituel
pendant l'été
nous allons être en grande difficulté le
personnel hospitalier est épuisé nous
avons encore des collègues qui sont en
arrêt maladie
nous manquons de lits donc il ya urgence
et vous savez là le gouvernement depuis
un mois nous amuse avec son secteur de
la santé nous l'avons aucune proposition
concrète
aucun financement supplémentaire qui est
annoncé voilà donc
l'urgence de l'urgence deux dotés la
seine saint denis des moyens pour
l'hôpital pour l'école pour les
transports
et puis pour les rémunérations pour les
salaires parce que vous savez on va une
pauvreté qui est catastrophique
un certain nombre de patients
aujourd'hui renonce au soir parce que on
leur prescrit une consultation chez un
spécialiste
et quand il trouva spécialistes
disponibles avec dépassements
d'honoraires eh bien ils peuvent pas le
payer donc ils n'y vont pas ils
attendent et ils arrivent aux urgences
de l'hôpital
quelques semaines plus tard avec une
pathologie qui s'est aggravée vous voyez
donc il y à vraiment maintenant
nécessité d'avoir des réponses que l'on
réclame
écoutez depuis depuis 20 ans depuis 20
ans nono nous lançons ce cri d'alarmé et
aujourd'hui la crise a montré que nos
demandes étaient totalement justifiée
totalement justifiée avec la priorité
j'imagine c'est l'augmentation des
salaires pour les infirmières qui sont
les moins bien payés de l' ocde
si la crise revenait à l'automne le
gouvernement dit on sera prêt donc pour
vous ce sera pas le cas non le
gouvernement ment comme il a menti
pendant la crise sur les masques sur les
thèses que vous avez vu enfin le linge
le directeur général de la santé devant
la commission donc un parlementaire qui
ment aussi il faut aujourd'hui un
langage de vérité
waltraud mots il se pose un problème
avec ce gouvernement quelle est la
légitimité aujourd'hui ce gouvernement
si nous avons de nouveau des ministres
des hauts fonctionnaires qui continue à
mentir
y compris devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire voilà pour qu'ils
arrêtent il ya la réalité de terrain
c'est celle que nous dénonçons moi je
suis sur le terrain je suis à l'hôpital
est aujourd'hui moi je dis que si
effectivement d'autres mesures celles
que nous avons demandé avec des prises
par le gouvernement nous aurions pu
éviter des morts
et si on veut éviter des morts cet été
et l'hiver prochain il ya besoin de
répondre de répondre à nos demandes et à
nos urgences que nous avons listé dans
cette lettre adressée au président macro
très court christophe prudhomme vous
parliez du terrain évidemment
de la connaissance du terrain le conseil
scientifique qui est auditionné en ce
moment justement par les parlementaires
a fait beaucoup d'erreurs
écoutez le conseil scientifique pourquoi
mettre en place un conseil scientifique
vous savez il n'y a pas de vérité vraie
on a vu qu'il y avait des polémiques
chez les scientifiques tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord nous sommes pas
d'accord entre médecins et bien il faut
que le gouvernement écoute l'ensemble
des médecins y compris quand il ya des
avis contradictoires et c'est le rôle du
politique de trancher de faire un choix
et pas de se reposer sur quelques
scientifiques qui l'a choisi pour se
dédouaner de ses responsabilités
voilà donc nous pouvons donner des
conseils mais c'est aux politiques de
prendre leurs responsabilités
après avoir pris des conseils qui
peuvent parfois je vous le dis être
contradictoire c'est ça la science ça va
à une époque et bien il y avait certains
qui disait que la terre était plate et
le disait avec la terre était ronde hier
une polémique
et puis on a pu trancher que au bout
d'un certain temps
et bien voilà aujourd'hui nous avons des
as certitudes et donc il faut savoir
gérer la crise au jour le jour et sera
prendre des décisions au jour le jour et
ne pas repousser ses décisions parce que
c'est le pire ne rien décider
et bien c'est une catastrophe merci
beaucoup christophe prudhomme d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france 0